aux studios de billancourt avant les
extérieurs en espagne en italie
jean seberg et jean paul belmondo on
tourner les premières scènes
d'échappement libre vos yeux d'amour
vous rire me faut maintenant qu'est ce
que vous allez faire l'amour de louis
est un message comme quoi l'amour dans
cette histoire humoristique aux
policiers le jeune réalisateur jean
becker a reconstitué pour la première
fois le couple célèbre de à bout de
souffle échappement libre safin de
poursuites d'après le titre
c'est un film de poursuite oui c'est ce
sont deux jeunes gens et reporters et
l'autre photographes qui se rencontrent
au moyen d'une organisation qui fait du
trafic dehors on le confie une voiture
et cette voiture est maquillée et
transporte une certaine somme d'argent
en lingots et un moment donné de
l'histoire
le garçon ces lingots lui manque un
petit peu au cerveau il décide de la
garder
c'est à partir de ce moment là que ça
devient
un échappement libre parce que il
s'échappe il est poursuivi par ces
trafiquants qui doit passer d'entrée
donnait alors on va se mettre à l'agenda
ou pas cette news télévision
cécile il a la dent ils vont faire pour
un répertoire était comme si on tournait
une prise oui oui comme ça se perd mais
aviez juste je me tiens à évaluer avant
de faire un commerce
oui mais vous vous gardez votre jeu
non mais c'est ça parce qu'un principe
je fais avec habillés pour la télévision
et puis j'aime je tiens pas tellement
que ce soit au plus un peu moteur belle
marquise pour beaux yeux d'amour mourir
me font maintenant qu'est ce que vous
allez faire l'amour enfin une fois dites
moi j'ai une super d'en juger par cette
semaine voilà un rôle assez sexy oui oui
si vous voulez peut-être plus carla
l'habitude de ne voir sauf qu'il faut
dire que avec le même partenaire dans à
bout de souffle
nous étions quand même un bon quart
d'heure sous des draps très honorable
c'est la première fois que vous
retrouvez belmondo depuis à bout de
souffle mais oui je suis ravie
d'ailleurs parce que je crois que c'est
mon partenaire préféré si vous voulez
pas ça sa décontraction et son charme
très gentil façon vous même vous
beaucoup plus décontracté qu'il ya
quelques années
oui oui oui ça va je crois en général je
suis heureuse en tout cas je crois qu'un
étudiant détendu quand on est heureux
jean paul belmondo on peut dire que vous
êtes un abonné à la télévision on voit
souvent nous en plaignons pas
même qu'on voit très souvent au cinéma
car vous semblez additionner les films
les uns derrière les autres un rythme
extrêmement rapide
combien avez vous tourné deux films
l'année dernière
4 l'année d'avant 5
l'année d'avant encore à la cge bonne
mémoire - mais il semble que vous ayez
eu deux emplois au cinéma si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi tout d'abord celui des
gangsters des durs des personnages assez
tourmentée et ensuite maintenant des
fantaisistes bondissant quel est celui
qui se rapproche le but de votre vraie
nature le second suppose refus non et
c'est à dire que quand j'ai commencé à
faire ce métier j'ai commencé par faire
des joyeux lurons
et puis aussi les marais et j'ai changé
un peu d'emplois parce que vous êtes un
peu curieuse d'ailleurs on va pas eu
tellement haut comique mais maintenant
je reviens un petit peu puis pas que
j'en aurais joué trop chaud très content
de rejouer les tourmenter les types qui
se prend la tête à deux mains
c'est un an et demi passés loin des
caméras jean paul belmondo a repris
cette semaine le chemin des plateaux
il tourne au sous la direction de robert
enrico sur près mon temps à voyager j'ai
fait beaucoup de beaucoup de films où je
voyageais mais c'était toujours pour
travailler là je suis parti en voyage
pour moi qu'en amérique au mexique tout
ça ça vous apporter beaucoup de joie
beaucoup et les voyages par machettes
mais ce que en un an et demi vous avez
eu le temps de penser à ce qu'ils
étaient devenus jean paul belmondo avait
j'avais un professeur pasqua s'arrête et
georges leroy d'un homme admirable
disait toujours que arriver à des
moments dans la carrière il fallait
faire le point naples est sain et moi
j'avais fait quand même 40 films en
relativement peu de temps et depuis 17
ans resté tout le temps en train de
jouer la comédie
alors durant les voyages comme ça sur
les plages de temps en feront jamais le
temps de penser à recharger les accus
une vive émotion et mouvements divers
dans les milieux cinématographiques
après l annonce faite par le conseil
d'administration de la cinémathèque
française du remplacement de son
directeur fondateur henri langlois par
monsieur pierre barben chargés d'enlever
organiser la gestion le conseil
d'administration a en outre l'intention
de permettre à henri langlois de
continuer à assurer un rôle décisif dans
la vie artistique de la cinémathèque
dans des activités de recherche et de
création
après le succès de la cuisine un décor
de bois et de fourrure pour le
fantastique du songe d'une nuit d'été de
shakespeare occire que demont marque par
le théâtre du soleil direction ariane
mnouchkine
c'est un parti pris d'originalité
on a lu la pièce puis on a trouvé que ça
n'était pas qu on avait pensé d'abord ce
n'était pas une féerie ce n'est
peut-être pas tellement une comédie
c'était une pièce plus plus ambigu plus
profonde plus plus cruelle si vous
m'aimez
oh
donnez moi la main
au théâtre du châtelet où se déroule
chaque soir avec succès les
représentations du prince de madrid
l'association des concerts colonne placé
sous la direction de pierre dervaux
recevait des autres dom marche le
violoniste soviétique leonid que blanc
qui en compagnie de sa femme et de son
fils pavel ont interprété cet après-midi
le concerto pour trois violons de
vivaldi